hello everyone and welcome to another
really fun game from the usgs
championship 2021. uh we we're gonna
skip around nine as round nine was uh
all draws and nothing really happened or
affected the standing so it was a pretty
much a snooze fest but here a wonderful
game from round eight the run that we
already covered but it's john burke
versus wesley so and it's um basically a
story about uh how uh one person uh
prepared something special for the other
one but then instead of bringing
surprises uh he was uh surprised himself
well you're gonna see what i mean by
this uh so let's uh just check it out so
uh berk with the white pieces opens with
e4 now we have e5 by wesley knight to
have knight to c6 and john goes for
bishop to b5 the uh rui lopez we have
knight to f6 going for the berlin
defense d3 and bishop to c5 we have c3
and the both players castle so this is
all very standard many many games in
this exact same line um
we have rook uh sorry castles we have
rook to e8 by black uh and now uh knight
beat d2 uh we have a6 chasing away the
bishop and bishop to a for now and this
is uh we've been covering a lot of lines
in the berlin defense and especially
this
d3 bishop the c5 line uh and it's a
position that occurs very often and this
position also occurred
many times the b5 is the most common
move played here uh levon aaron played
it against the teemo rajab of almassi
played it against maxine vashila grav
so many top grand masters also enjoyed
this exact same position but here we
have d5 by wesley so trying to
catch uh
burke
off guard and it's also a very tricky
line so what do you play here uh the
position was reached in a very top tier
game in 2016 in the grand chess tour
between vishwanathan and hikaru nakamura
where anand continued with queen to e
e2 and just getting the queen away from
the d file and putting more uh defense
to the to the pawn here
but here we don't have this here in this
game we have the immediate d4 so this is
uh
what uh what burke played uh and it is
now uh only as of move nine that we have
a completely new game uh so let's see
how wesley deals with this with e
captures on d4 c captures on d4 and now
uh now is the uh well a wonderful moment
in the game uh where wesley played
bishop to a7 but uh you could try
something else the problem is you can't
go after the pawn uh because your knight
is pinned the bishop here is just in the
way but what you could do is play b5 and
now you are threatening to win the pawn
if the bishop moves we're just going to
win this pawn for free so here d
captures and c5 is kind of forced the b
captures on a4 and if e captures on d5
we're going to capture here and if queen
captures an a4 we can develop the bishop
and black uh really has no no worries
here uh but perhaps the wesley this is
um maybe trading down a a little bit uh
too much to too soon so he wants to keep
uh all the chances alive for
for quite some time so bishop back to a7
and now e5 challenging this knight
knight to e4 and now bishop captures on
c6 b captures on c6 doubling wesley c
pawn and since the knight is already
attacked twice uh
uh one so we're going to attack it twice
and white's next move seems uh only
natural white plays queen to c2 puts
pressure on the knight puts pressure on
the c6 pawn
but this is exactly the move that allows
wesley to
just take complete control of the game
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea that wesley played
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding such a
beautiful active move and uh for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course bishop f5
uh now bishop to f5 uh developing a
piece uh that's already you know uh good
enough in itself but you are x-raying
this queen on c2 and not only that you
are threatening ideas like night whoops
you are threatening ideas like knight
the g3 opening up a discovery on the
queen and also on the rook here the
knight also will be defending the bishop
so white has to do something about this
uh you could capture here of course
that's possible for example if knight
captures bishop captures we attack the
queen now the queen
can move or go after this c6 pawn so
this is definitely possible but in the
game uh burke played queen captures on
c6 right away and now he allows wesley
to just continue mounting pressure we
have rook to e6 pushing the queen back
queen to a4 and now c5 getting rid of
this um uh backwards c pawn uh attacking
white's center because white has a
beautiful d4 in the e5 pawn chain here
you could also consider rook to g6 it's
it's a wonderful move because uh it's
very hard for white to unwind here the
queen is all the way on the queen side
not helping out with the defense you
can't really capture here because we're
gonna capture with the pawn and then
this knight has to move regarding the
these squares with the queen so
black will definitely be better here but
wesley decides for c5 it's important to
eliminate white's strong center so d
captures on c5 knight captures attacking
the queen and queen to f4 now putting
pressure on the bishop
and now comes bishop to d3 another
beautiful move by wesley attacking
white's rook here and the problem is if
you move the rook then we play bishop c2
now we're threatening knights to d3
attacking the rook and the queen and
here uh it's very very hard to find the
decent moves for white if you go for the
counter attack uh with knight to g5 we
can simply block knight to d3 is still
coming and if queen h4 uh trying to say
okay if knight to d3 then the bishop no
longer guards the h7 pawn we can simply
move the bishop back we don't really
need it here so you've avoided the
knights the d3 uh trap but uh still
black's position is definitely to be
preferred here this bishop is a monster
this bishop is an even a greater monster
you have a beautiful pass to deep d-pawn
that's protected the knight is ready to
go anywhere so it's a it's a really fine
position for black
so uh that's not what burke played burke
went for the move that you always have
to look for when you're playing with the
white pieces and that of course is pawn
to b4 now he's trying to sacrifice the
exchange here and should we accept this
then he's going to play b captures on c5
and get a beautiful pass pawn here
wesley has to tend to the bishop and
after the bishop moves we're going to
play knight b3 defend our pawn here
developer bishop then put the rook on c1
and we're gonna have a nice protected
pass pawn as well uh
that's already well fairly far advanced
uh so after b4 wesley goes for knight to
e4
he could go for for capturing the rook
but it's just um uh he he has something
better planned uh for the moment you
can't move the rook because then the f2
pawn falls the knight is now making sure
of this rather than capturing uh the
knight here it's uh
well there's really nothing better so
knight captures on e4 we have d captures
on e4 attacking the uh the knight here
knight to g5 now attacking f7 and the
rook on e6 so wesley has to defend with
rook to e7 and now bishop to b2 now
putting the bishop to this beautiful
diagonal at some point even e6 might be
played trying to open up the diagonal
for the bishop to come alive but now
wesley does it uh
does it sooner now you could just go for
the rook rook captures an f1 there's
nothing wrong with that i mean who
amongst us would not go for the rook
here but wesley plays e3 here and this
is uh just just showing pure class uh
he's saying now okay you can't capture
with the queen my bishop is defending
this you have to capture with this pawn
and i'm going to ruin your pawn
structure and then have a lot of very
interesting tactics here plus i'm also
going to capture the rook on the next
move so f captures an e3 there's nothing
better here if bishop captures on f1
rook captures on f1 and now queen to d3
uh you can't go for f6 right away it
seems like a great idea for example pawn
captures bishop captures with check
picks up the queen the problem is queen
c4 check and then we capture on f6 and
black doesn't really have anything here
so after rook captures an f1 we have
queen to d3 now threatening bishop
captures on e3 to win the queen and now
bishop to d4 so challenging the bishop
here not allowing bishop captures on e3
wesley traits here we have d captures
now white also has a very strong pawn
center again and rook to d8 now but
still uh wesley's up the exchange and
that pawn uh chain in the center will
not be advancing forward anytime soon so
knight to f3 adding a defender to the d4
pawn just queen c3 wesley says there is
nothing for you on the king side there's
nothing for you in the center i'm just
gonna go gobble up these queen side
pawns
and that's enough for me to win the game
and now uh here a3 is actually a very
interesting move it seems like you're
guarding this pawn and trying to give up
this pawn but if of course the queen
captures an a3 uh then you have some
very interesting knight stage four to f5
ideas and then it could get well it
could get very very ugly uh you know
it's very complicated white has this
also the knight now joins the attack so
wesley doesn't want to allow this um uh
sorry uh so so a3 was an interesting
option here but white missed it and
white played h4 now he wants to start
the attack as soon as possible because
he thinks he's out of um out of options
but a3 was very very interesting here so
here queen captures on b4 wesley just
grabs the pawn h5 now now h6 wesley
stops the advancement and now even g4
and this is now going all out either it
works or it doesn't and now we have rook
to b7 by wesley
interestingly here f6 was a viable
option because now after e captures an
f6 and there's really nothing better uh
we're just gonna play rook to f7 and we
just opened up the f file for our rooks
to uh you know wreak havoc on so after
queen uh e3 let's say rook captures hero
you can bring the other rook here you
can bring the queen wherever and it's
just a very very strong position for
black so after g4 wesley decided to go
the other way around he played rook to
b7 now queen e4 centralizing the queen
and also maybe hoping to start advancing
those pawns at some point but rook to b6
now now you have to be careful if the
queen moves that rook could become a
target but also we're just stopping this
pawn from going to e6
so queen to c2 this move i really don't
understand uh probably the idea is to
move the queen away uh from from the
fourth rank so you can maybe play rook
to d1 and start advancing that pawn one
at one time uh but it's still uh
probably that so wesley just continues
to rook d to b8 triples up on the b file
rook to d1 and now queen to a3 the
simplest way to go uh the rook is now
coming to b2 and there's not a lot white
white can do here so rook d3 attacking
the queen but still rook to b2 offering
a queen trade and now the problem is if
you try to avoid the queen trade queen
captures here and you're just uh
dead lost here and also if you move the
queen to somewhere like c4 we're also
just gonna capture offer a queen trade
and the rook to g2 is a very strong move
then the other rook can come to b1 or
this rook can come to b1 right away uh
all depends on what white plays but
after rook to b2 we had the simple rook
captures on a3 uh queen trade occurred
wesley played rook captures on c2 and it
was uh in this position on move 34 that
john m burke resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
he's down material okay he's up a pawn
but he cannot
grab an a6 and other than that there's
really nothing you can do the two rooks
are simply too strong rook the b1 is the
threat of checkmate uh so you can't even
go for the a6 pawn and it would be uh
just extremely
pointless continuing this for example if
king f1 trying to avoid mate so we can
block with 91 we're still just gonna
play this and after knight to e1 we can
not play really anything rook h2 again
or threatens checkmate so it's just a
very ugly position to play
uh in any possible one uh so yeah after
rook captures on c2 he resigned uh and
it was uh very very interesting so who
uh who who out prepared who he here yeah
because uh burke seems to have uh
played a very nice line and he uh found
the line that uh you know he he might be
able to take on wesley with the white
pieces but then uh you know as soon as
they uh went out of the the known
territory uh this simple simple position
that uh i mean it's such a simple
position that everyone would play this
queen to c2 it's so normal to to play
something like this uh but it just shows
you how dangerous it is to go for for a
poison pawn even if you don't know if
it's poison they you know maybe maybe
just avoid going for the pawn altogether
as this is classical chess wesley would
not allow this if it was you know
playable
uh but yeah uh that's the game i hope
you guys enjoyed it uh in the lead as
yesterday since all of the
uh runs uh games from round nine were
drawn uh it's uh wesley lenderman and
sebian are leading the tournament uh and
we'll see uh who who
who will it be after round ten i think
uh ray robson and um
[Music]
who who who who's tied with him uh i
think robson and dominguez and then it's
uh fabi who's trailing by a full point
behind the leaders but we're gonna
show the standings at some point that is
a promise uh so yeah once again hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
tom darrell you'll never walk alone uh
hb mr hoodie guy and michael kennedy for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
usgs championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your friday